I'm dr. Greg Sandler and I'm very
excited to tell you about a course that
I have just finished building in
curious.com
philosophy of religion which consists of
16 mini lessons each of which is
anywhere from 10 to 30 minutes long and
includes some exercises I'm going to
show you some of the course from the
inside and then tell you a little bit
more about it and if you're interested
at the very end of this this video I'm
going to provide you with a link that
you can use to get some credit with
curious if you're interested in trying
it out or subscribing this philosophy of
religion class like every curious course
consists of a set of lessons I'd like to
show you what a lesson looks like and
what is included in it so I've picked
this one which deals with a classic
problem in the philosophy of religion
the problem of evil the lessons are like
little mini courses each of which is
broken down into several sections
dealing with important aspects or issues
when students are engaged with the
lesson they have the opportunity to
click on these exercises each exercise
opens up a multiple-choice question
which students can use to test their
learning and comprehension and then when
you click on it you notice that it will
tell you if you've got it right that you
did get it right and if you got it wrong
well it'll tell you that as well another
feature I really like about curious
courses from an instructor's perspective
is the fact that I can add attachments
some of these are further reading
suggestions with Amazon links some of
them might be links to online resources
like the internet encyclopedia of
philosophy entries i've also uploaded
handouts which you can click on and then
download for yourself as pdfs so if
you're somebody who has watched and
enjoyed and benefited from my many
youtube videos on philosophy or if
you're somebody who's actually taken a
longer more intensive course with me
this is something you might say in
between
it offers a lot more interactivity and
and you know fortified learning than a
simple video does but it's not quite so
intensive or as big of an investment you
might say as a course you'll see here
are scrolling up the various titles for
the sixteen lessons the topics that this
course is composed of I'm really proud
of this course because I made a
deliberate effort to try to include some
of the really key issues and topics in
the philosophy of religion I'm adding
two links to the video description which
are codes that you can use for
promotions to try things out with
curious if you're interested in my
philosophy of religion course in
particular or any of the other material
that I've already loaded or will be
adding to curious I plan by the way I'm
adding quite a lot to this or if you're
interested in curious more broadly you
can try it out they give you a 30-day
trial and I use it myself I actually
enjoy this quite a bit the activity of
producing things and spending a little
time learning something I'm curious it's
a great site and I strongly recommend it